bonsoir nous sommes le 16 octobre
nouvelle édition du 7 8 votre rendez
vous quotidien pour faire l'information
pour faire le point sur l'information
locale sur tv fil sur ce plateau pierre
frelot au président de la fcpe 78
bonjour à vous dans un instant également
touma dire husser la présidente de l'ape
est soixante dix huit avec vous de nous
parlerons avec les deux représentants
des parents d'élèves là nous parlerons
de la réforme de l'éducation nationale
rythme scolaire devoirs à la maison
formation des enseignants un projet de
loi devrait voir le jour au cours du
mois de novembre
c'est sa première ce soir valérie
auribeau bonsoir la nouvelle
spécialistes de la rédaction questions
d'environnement et d'innovation première
chronique pour vous ce soir et vous
allez nous parler d'un sujet pour le
moins compliquée pour le moins pointu la
création d'un nouveau cluster c'est à
magny les hameaux oui 1 kloster un
wilfried et et non une pépinière
d'entreprises il ya une petite nuance
entre les deux le kloster demande
beaucoup plus de synergie entre les
entrepreneurs et nous verrons ça tout à
l'heure avec nos deux invités ce sera au
cours de la chronique innovation dans
une vingtaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure valérie avant de faire le point
sur le reste de l'actualité du jour est
de débattre donc de cette réforme est de
l'éducation avec nos invités nous avons
en ligne olivier de la sphère bonsoir à
vous
bonsoir olivier de la sphère conseiller
général ps des yvelines comme pour cinq
autres villes vous deviez présenter hier
à la mission française du patrimoine et
des cultures alimentaires
le dossier de versailles pour accueillir
la cité de la gastronomie on en a parlé
sur ce plateau un mauvaise surprise le
maire de versailles avait fait parvenir
sans vous le dire visiblement auparavant
un courrier annonçant le retrait de la
candidature de versailles
donc vous êtes présentés vous n'étiez
pas au courant que la candidature était
annulé comment tout cela est possible du
tout c'est la question qu'on se pose
c'est vrai que on avait on avait
vraiment bien travaillé pour proposer un
beau projet et on regrette cet étudiant
parce que finalement on était deux
partenaires a présenté ce projet et le
conseil général et la mairie c'est un
projet que j'avais initié avec avec la
mairie et c'est vrai far était bien
qu'on puisse en parler ensemble avant de
reprendre une telle décision c'est le
quotidien dresse maintenant que je
regrette le plus c'est pour versailles
est vrai que on avait un beau projet qui
permettait enfin de faire sortir les
touristes
du château et de les faire venir dans
versailles pour dans nos restaurants
dans nos commerçants auraient fait plus
le plus dans cette intégrale que je vois
je suis déçu pour le projet cité de la
gastronomie à la ville de versailles ne
veut pas elle aurait dû s'installer dans
les anciens locaux de la poste sur l'une
des avenues principales de versailles
est ce que depuis vous vous êtes
entretenu avec françois de mazières
après avec le maire le député maire
d'ailleurs de versailles de se retraite
cette candidature en tout cas de son
choix de ne pas soutenir ce dossier et
de finalement pas revenir sur ce qui
avait été pour l'instant jusqu'à présent
envisagé non valeur alors on va le faire
rapidement vous avez toujours pas eu de
réponse alors vous étiez venu nous
présenter ce dossier vous avez également
parlé des financements parce que
visiblement c'est ce qui pose problème
du côté de la ville de versailles les
financements n'aurait pas été assez
solide vous nous aviez dit avoir ces
financements ça veut dire que ces
partenaires vont rester derrière vous
vous soutenir et éventuellement c'est en
tout cas sous un autre nom la cité de la
gastronomie pourra voir le jour oui il
me réclame y en a aujourd'hui
effectivement tout le avec l'engouement
qu'on a pu avoir sur ce projet et il
avait de la part des partenaires
financiers mais également de la part
d'un certain nombre de méfaits et est
prêt aussi investir sur un tel projet
parce que y'avait il y avait l'idée
forte pour pour les marques pour les
marques françaises nous avait beaucoup
de marques aujourd'hui je vienne vers
leurs grands chevaux aussi au château
jaffa qui a une signification en fête
pour tous leurs clients internationaux
je pense qu'effectivement il peut y
avoir une autre vocation à trouver à ce
site va trouver à ce projet là si la
réflexion pour va pouvoir pour avoir
mais je ne désespère pas de voir quelque
chose donc pour la gastronomie française
avec celle organisée pour ce pour
l'industrie agroalimentaire pour
l'agroalimentaire en général
et pour la gastronomie des petits on va
voir si on peut continuer à quelque
chose et puis sinon mais on essaiera de
tt avec tous les partenaires qu'on avait
pu avoir pour pour versailles avait
d'aider les autres ou la ville qui sera
retenu pour pour l'habitat 90 alors
voila mais mon jeu je suis serein sur ce
dossier de croître et surtout
décevant pour versailles responsable une
belle qu'on avait une belle opportunité
de parler de versailles ados autrement
que par son histoire et
même si l agroalimentaire est allé très
très bien avec l'histoire
la cité de la gastronomie à versailles
ça ne verra pas le jour vous vous
appuyez notamment sur le jardin du
potager du roi on en a vu quelques
images pendant vous nous expliquer
pourquoi cette candidature finalement
n'avaient pas pu être présentés y
remercie olivier de la sphère la ville
de versailles retire cette candidature
reste en course pour cette cité de la
gastronomie lyon dijon tours ou encore
rungis verdict dans les prochaines
semaines et lyon ville favorite